in terms of the humanitarian corridors
that we've just heard about today how
hopeful are you that they will
work that russia will abide by what it
has said it will
i hope it will work this is pretty vital
literally at this moment so i'm happy
that at least
we've had
two two opportunities to bring him to
people in extremely difficult
circumstances and maybe for vulnerable
people to get out of those places uh of
course
the u.n the red cross we are still in
ukraine and we will do our best to take
advantage of these opportunities i hope
actually there will be more
opportunities in other places as well
because it's needed now this is not a
ceasefire this is nothing
which is what we need the cessation of
hostilities but at least it will help
save some lives
have you actually got
provisions and transport in place to
order to make use of these in the next
six hours
we
we've been preparing for that it depends
a lot on what the modalities are you
know we've done these things in other
places before syria for example so we
know how to do convoys
but we need to have the guarantees
respected as you said so we will have to
see how it moves
the logistical capacity is not the
biggest problem is the security
guarantees that need to be given and
maintained
well indeed you can't put any of your
people at risk as well
it will be great that some more people
can get out but of course there will be
those who can't what about those who are
left behind the fact that these
humanitarian corridors have been opened
up
does it make their position even more
perilous
look we've we've
been
targetly
resisting any pressure to get out of
ukraine we humanitarian organizations uh
red cross ngos because we want to
continue to bring assistance where we
can
it is a bit more easy in western ukraine
which is less hit by the conflict at the
moment it is much more difficult in the
eastern part that's why the humanitarian
corridors are good are useful but
it is true it is not easy at the moment
to bring assistance inside and this is
why we keep seeing people getting out of
the country i understand you're in
poland i'm here in moldova i was at the
border yesterday and this human
avalanche as i have called it continues
and is likely to increase
and and we've seen obviously on the
border with moldova with romania here in
poland there is an enormous humanitarian
effort underway
is is that the same on the other side of
the border on the ukrainian side
presumably it is a little more
challenging for you to get help there or
is that not the case
it's much more challenging on the other
side of the border because we depend on
how the conflict moves
and like you said we cannot go where
there is bombardment or insecurity
because
it would be futile and dangerous so we
have to take opportunities to study
almost the map of conflict and insert
ourselves in spaces that are safe and
bring assistance we work a lot
international organizations work a lot
with local groups local ukrainian
organizations because they have more
mobility more information and more
access
we've seen over a million people have
already moved from ukraine how many do
you fear in total we will see moving
across borders
as a matter of fact i think that by
tonight latest tomorrow the total number
of people that have crossed
out of ukraine will reach 1.5 million
where you know we were yesterday close
to 1.3 million i think poland yesterday
saw in one day alone a 100 000 people
crossing so it's it's going
exponentially and take a place like
moldova where i'm now and
where i was yesterday you must know this
place called palanca this border
crossing is 50 or 60 kilometers from
odessa one of the largest ukrainian
cities if odessa is also hit by the by
the war it's likely that a great deal of
its population will move in its
direction we have a planning figure and
i stress it's a planning figure of total
4 million refugees when we started i
thought well maybe this is you know god
forbid we reach that figure it's it's a
lot but now i'm getting worried that we
win
you think it could be even higher do you
think
i don't know it's really
anybody's guess at this point we have to
see how the company moves in ukraine it
depends really on that yesterday the
people i spoke to and the other day in
romania the same
you know it's very clear it's when
for example i saw people from odessa
already moving they said why did you
move they said we waited when the first
siren went off
first alarm that the maybe bombardment
we moved out so it's when when
especially aerial bombardments happen
that people get worried and want to get
their children out and as as president
zelensky mentioned earlier in his
statement we heard it
on your on your program um it's it's
when men stay behind
uh it's
women and children mostly crossing so we
are also seeing this huge population
mostly of women and children and it's a
pretty vulnerable population that we
need a lot of them
and that help needs to be sustained for
a long period of time it looks like
doesn't it
felipe grande the head of the un hcr
really grateful for your time today
thank you
thank you very much